den drei hasen wird mord vorgeworfen wie
häufig kommt so etwas vor
naja das seit einiger zeit kommt dass
immer häufiger vor
bislang hat man ganz normales
verkehrsstrafrecht angewandt aber seit
dem kudamm raser fall macht man das
jetzt regelmäßig das mord vorgeworfen
wird und das ist natürlich ein sehr
schwerer vorhof vielleicht können sie
uns noch mal genauer erklären was
bedeutet jetzt der mordvorwurf was muss
gegeben sein um diesem ort merkmale auch
wirklich durchsetzen zu können vor
gericht
also mord ist eine besondere variante
eines tötungsdelikts das bedeutet es ist
nicht nur ein mensch durch einen anderen
menschen oder durch die tat eines
anderen menschen ums leben gekommen
sondern da komm' besondere merkmale
hinzu die können subjektiv sein also
beim täter aus habgier oder aus
niedrigen beweggründen aber es kann eben
auch aus der wahl des mittels seien hier
gemeingefährlich mit 250 300 über die
autobahn zu rasen und die besonderheit
des mordes ist eben darauf gibt es nur
eine reaktion des rechtsstaates die
lebenslange freiheitsstrafe die dann
droht weil eben diese besonderen
merkmale vorliegen wenn eine wenn eine
lebenslange freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
wird dann bedeutet das in der regel auch
lebenslang und dass wir erst nach 15
jahren geschaut ob man überhaupt noch
mal über eine bewährung an entlassung
auf bewährung nach denken kann und wie
ist ihre juristische einschätzung
glauben sie oder halten dies für
wahrscheinlich dass die drei rate dann
auch letztendlich dann wegen mordes
verurteilt werden
das ist eine ganz schwierige sache bis
vor einigen jahren war das fast
undenkbar weil wie oft passiert so etwas
hat man schnell über die autobahn
das kann immer so etwas passieren dann
durch die entscheidung des
bundesgerichtshofs verkäufer einiger
zeit sagt er ja das kann mord sein und
mord da braucht man aber auch ein
vorsatz für den täter und den vorsatz
musste die staatsanwaltschaft und das
recht eben dem täter nachweisen vorsatz
bedeutet dabei auf der einen seite ja
man muss etwas wissen man muss wissen
dadurch dass ich so schnell unterwegs
bin kann so etwas passieren
das halte ich für relativ wahrscheinlich
denn also schnell unterwegs wird so
rücksichtslos durch die gegend fährt
dann weiß man dass das passieren kann
aber dass man braucht eine wollens
komponente wollen bedeutet
man muss zumindest ja sagen das ist mir
egal ich weiß das risiko das ist mir
egal
und wenn man das hier wirklich annehmen
bei jungen menschen über die autobahn
rasen um bei ihren kick zu bekommen
ist denen das dann egal wenn jemand
anders stirbt oder vielleicht auch sie
selber und das ist eine ganz schwierige
frage und er sagt der bundesgerichtshof
auch rasen bedeutet nicht immer mord
aber es kann mord sein
es kommt auf den einzelfall an und da
wird man hier noch ganz viel ermitteln
müssen auch die persönlichkeit der täter
hinterfragen müssen und das umfeld
aufklären wie sind die gestrickt sage
ihnen das wirklich egal
oder haben sie vielleicht insgeheim
gehofft wird schon gut gehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren